the family of a man stabbed 33 times on
an RTC bus now suing the Transit
Commission the bus company and the
driver 30-year-old Dominique Lucas was
on a bus in February when police say he
and 59-year-old Aaron Cole got into an
argument prosecutors say this video are
eight news now investigators obtain
shows Cole stabbing Lucas our
investigators learning the driver did
not stop the bus for nearly four minutes
even as Lucas pled for help the bus
company says the driver was on an
alternate route and couldn't stop in
traffic our own David Charn speaking
with Lucas's parents
they brought the bus all the time so
devastating
my only son
very close
the wrongful death lawsuit says RTC has
a duty to provide safety to its Riders
our eight news now investigators will
have a special report on this incident
coming up on Thursday